and chuckle don't eat or fighting so
what else you got what do you think of
that not my cup of tea but you know I
just watch it the I for sure well I
watch it yeah we'll watch it when you
look like I'm paying for it
there's some people say it shouldn't
happen well no I don't think it
shouldn't happen I look at it more like
if I see I think if Chuck Liddell was
still employee the UFC he can pay four
hundred thousand dollars just to chill
whatever he was doing for the UFC he
would not be fighting I think there's
more of a money play which bums me out
because I think Chuck Liddell Tito Ortiz
what they did for the sport should be
compensated for the rest of their lives
it bums me out they have to fight to
make money that bums me out I don't know
if Tito does so much because he was very
smart Chuck you know it seems like maybe
that's the what's going on there but but
he also has been saying no you got to
wonder what where this coming from but
he has been saying that he misses it and
it's that was his favorite thing misses
it yeah but it's different like if if
we're gonna live forever if we're gonna
live forever I would say yeah I
definitely don't do it because you're
just gonna keep damaging yourself if
you're not gonna live forever then
you're well let's say it's 48 so let's
say we're gonna live to a hundred mm-hmm
let's say Chuck lives to a hundred now
he's halfway there being friendly
right now let's say live done never no
absolution Edison brother I have another
one of my I'm thirty five thirty solid
years left of me so let's say chuck is
gonna Madison's son sighs oh I'm
big though great house Great Danes bro
so let's say he lives to a hundred he's
basically halfway there right dude at
the halfway mark fighting it just it
can't be healthy man like imagine being
50 fighting Joe and you're the exception
you know like you're in phenomenal shape
it's yeah but I don't want to get hit
you don't get hit in the face now it's
not gonna be pretty
not in the head especially if you had
all those years of listen I'm not hating
on it there's a market for it do your
thing I take like I said to me it's more
of a sad story
well not like I think they should be
compensated or like I want them to
parlay their careers like a Michael
Strahan or Kobe Bryant you know where
there are legends and then they move on
to do great things I agree but I also if
they wanted to compete it was
cuz they wanted to compete I wonder
where it makes sense to tell them they
can't or they shouldn't because if they
want to do it if they both want to do it
like if they had money and they're like
oh so what is it about it is it the
motivation that bothers me like what is
it about a fight like that is the fact I
think it's the motivation you created a
little bit right a little bit because
see I think Tito did better financially
you know I think Tito's line he did
really well in Bellator mm-hmm he might
actually want this fight just to fight
Chuck again I think so I think Tito's on
a different trajectory correct yeah I
mean he's been fighting and doing well
you know yeah he's he's still a
formidable guy he's a beast that was a
big fella yeah yeah that's both great